hey
Youtubers it's Charlie so we finally got an
official version of the daredevil season two
trailer got her first look at Elektra and
the punisher the most of this breakdown is
going to be about them because daredevil is
the intersection of a lot of different types
of TV a lot of different comic book genres
you think of John Byrne Thole playing the
punisher is being like Omar from the wire
because so many TV writers that work on shows
like this are in love with the wire what they're
selling it as is daredevil versus punisher
as an eagle putt punisher obviously a good
character but just a really crazy good character
the daredevil's connect to stop and going
over the line daredevil will totally push
people over the sides of buildings but he
won't kill them punisher doesn't have that
problem he is totally happy to shoot every
person in the face if you're looking for a
comic book to read about daredevil versus
punisher is really easy because there is a
comic book called daredevil versus punisher
I just recommend you read that it's a six
issue series so it's not that long in every
single title is a play on the idea of crossing
the line like issue one is called good deeds
bad deeds then there's the big squeeze victory
now!
Over the line the unraveling then the second
chances the name of the last title so the
Netflix series season two is going to be all
about the punisher unleashing his brand of
justice daredevil trying to help people and
help the punisher at the same time help the
punisher to stop killing people why then you
ask is punisher probably not can end up being
a member of the defenders team up with just
a sidestep in the Civil War territory Captain
America's Civil War this is really funny memory
I have of Marvel Civil War of the comic book
Civil War where punisher save Spiderman Spiderman
almost gets killed punisher season takes them
back to Captain America's underground team
punisher offers his help the team But the
rest of the heroes just look at him and shake
their heads is you you are is way too crazy
were going to go ahead and pass you just keep
doing your own thing so punisher regardless
of the outcome of daredevil season to you
just can continue to do his own thing although
he will continue to show up during the Netflix
series a lot of you're also asking is punisher
going to end up in the movies is a freaking
huge character John Berthoud looks like you
can have an amazing performance why wouldn't
you put them in the movies the only answer
I have for that is is I think that what they
would do is it just have him cameo in the
avengers films are likely that the big team
up films there have been rumors that he's
been seen on the set of Captain America's
Civil War but I can confirm that and there's
already so many characters in that easily
think of punisher in this Netflix universe
and in the movie universe is being kind of
a free agent I think given the tone of the
character he probably wouldn't work really
well on agent to shield because it's on ABC
it's a little bit lighter tone daredevil can
be is dark and gritty as it wants is that
I feel like if they try to take them on agent
to shield they would have to hamstring the
character a little bit so that's one place
I'm hoping to not see him show up what about
electro though well she's also kind of a good
character who has been bad in the past she
is a creation of Frank Miller the first time
she showed up in the comics she was a bad
character like she was part of the hand but
then she's also been part of the chaste she's
been part of thunderbolts she's gone all over
the place but she is not quite as crazy as
punisher so I am expecting her to team up
with daredevil eventually when they first
meet she's probably going to be daredevil's
enemy that that that would be very true to
the comics I mexicana hoping to see them fight
quite a bit it does look like based on his
face covering the chill be part of the hand
and the instant will be back for season two
so they will continue that storyline of the
chaste versus the hand that's like a mystical
battle I think I'll kinda save a little bit
of that for iron fist to do because his character
is rooted in more supernatural things than
daredevil is this character that everybody
saw in daredevil season one this is stone
he just one of the members of the chaste so
not really expecting to see a ton of supernatural
thing shop in daredevil season to I think
it will be relatively street-level practical
is a street-level heroes are going to pay
street-level problems but I think that they
will allude to supernatural things particularly
through this chaste versus hand storyline
the really cool thing that Mike Coulter unit
was playing with Cajun Jessica Jones right
now said is that they're currently filming
glue cage although we probably won't see a
whole lot from that till after daredevil season
to either promoting Jessica Jones daredevil
season two right now first things first then
though start promoting glue cage both daredevil
and Jessica Jones are Hells kitchen base shows
like that area of New York the weird thing
is is like in this trailer we don't see the
avengers tower the cameras just pointed at
the wrong part of New York just imagine the
avengers tower being so little bit offscreen
it's in Midtown Hells kitchen is a little
bit further south of that glue cage on the
other hand might take place up in Harlem or
even up in the Bronx like like a slightly
different part of New York as they continue
to do Netflix series I expect their sphere
of influence the growth like daredevil season
one was highly localized to Hells kitchen
I think I'll start radiating out from New
York a little bit is the serious get on and
on to have a confirmed yet we haven't seen
Jessica Jones yet but I'd I do think that
each of these Netflix series will continue
on is a long as Netflix wants them to continue
on they're all very successful so we can see
like five seasons of each of the shows are
much easier to shoot because they only do
13 episodes of season they don't do like 23
so it's a lot easier to get the actors distance
of the question I know you guys are all asking
to know they haven't said anything about iron
fist only that Coulson really wants to be
in it in real life Clark Greg's favorite Marvel
character is Danny Rand so naturally he would
want to be in that series of Coulson does
show up it'll probably be during iron fist
both before the big defenders team up but
it is time to get hyped in case you guys didn't
know Jessica Jones all dropped all the episodes
will drop on November 20, to do as many videos
as I can for that I pry will be able to do
like 13 just because it'll all drop it wants
to try to at least like five or six video
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
were probably due for Captain America's Civil
War trailer in the next month to I've already
done a couple punisher daredevil videos all
put some bonus links and description if you
want to learn a little bit more about their
history in the comics I feel like I need to
go by like my daredevil teachers now he like
three or four new daredevil shirts what he
has wait for my next video I have a The Walking
Dead Q&A in there a couple other trailers
from New York, can't I may or may not get
to those I'll try to do you guys can click
here to catch up from The Walking Dead episode
one last night is freaking crazy let's all
remember Shane of the punisher and you can
click here for the viral teaser from Batman
view Superman just teasing some brainiac things
I think thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tonight